大家好,歡迎來原石咖啡,我是俊元
今天是手沖咖啡慢慢來
要跟大家分享的是
如何調整咖啡酸甜的風味
在萃取咖啡的過程當中
有許多的參數都會去影響到咖啡酸甜的風味
在手沖咖啡沖煮的手法裡面
我們在注水的前段
就是在萃取咖啡風味的一個關鍵時刻
在注水的前段如果我們的水量比較大
注水的速度比較快
它會讓咖啡的風味比較呈現的是
酸質、明亮、比較清爽的一個口感
如果在萃取的前段我們使用慢慢注水的方式
它比較能夠凸顯的是它的甜跟厚實的感受
那我們今天就用這兩種不同的沖煮方式
來跟大家分享
萃取的結果會有什麼樣的不同
那我們就先來沖煮咖啡
我們同時來看兩壺咖啡沖煮的影片
今天我們使用同一支咖啡豆
研磨的刻度也是相同的
水溫也都一樣是90度
我們在萃取的最前面的悶蒸
用一樣的方式
因為我認為悶蒸要做的是排氣跟讓咖啡粉濕潤
所以通常在悶蒸這個階段
我們不會做太多的一個變化
那门针大约30秒之后
我们就会开始来做前段的注水
那这个注水就是我们这一次
要跟大家分享的一个重点
我们可以看到右边这一壶
我是用一个比较大的水量
它上面的流量达到了10左右的一个流量
那左边这一壶
我们是用比较小的一个水量
它的流量大约是4到5之间所以在第一段的注水我们用了两个对比一壶用了将近10这样子的一个水量比较大的水量来充足那另外一壶我们用比较小的水量
用大概4到5之间
不过不管你的水量是大或小
我们都要有一定的搅拌
一定的扰动
才能让咖啡粉里面
它的酸甜好的味道
能够充分的发挥出来
所以我们在比较大的水量
沖煮的時候我們看到它水面上升會比較快
那咖啡跟水的接觸
它會是一個比較大面積的比較快速的
那會萃取到的是比較酸質明亮
那口感是比較清爽的一個風味
那左邊這一壺呢
我們在前段的注水是慢慢的攪拌的狀態的話
那它容易是有一個比較長時間的攪拌
那它的甜跟厚實度就會比較明顯
那在後面我們就把水補到225克
我們今天用15克的咖啡粉
鑄水要225克是1比15的分水比
那在後面這一段我們就用相同的方式
慢慢的鑄水慢慢的繞圈
把最後的濃度調整到一致
那我們要來試試看
這兩壺咖啡萃取出來的結果
它的風味會有什麼不同
那我們就來試喝看看這兩壺咖啡
我右手邊的這一壺是前段注水比較慢的沖法
那我左手邊的這一壺是前段注水比較快的一個沖法
我們剛才試喝過這兩壺咖啡
注水比較慢的這一壺咖啡風味它比較能夠呈現出咖啡的甜感跟厚實度那注水比較快的這樣子的沖法的話它凸顯出來的是咖啡的酸質
比較明亮的口感跟比較清爽的一個風味
所以當我們在沖煮咖啡
如果你想要調整你的風味的時候
你可以利用你前段注水的速度
來做一個風味的調整
如果當你拿到一支咖啡
你試沖的結果覺得你希望它能夠把酸更凸顯一點
更明亮一點的話
你可以試著把悶蒸後的這段注水
它的注水量大一點速度快一點
那能夠讓它的風味往比較清爽的走向去走
那如果你沖煮一支咖啡
覺得你需要凸顯的是它的甜跟厚實的話
那你可以試著在前面這一段的注水
讓它的速度慢一點點
注水量小一點點
但是要注意的是
你水量小但是你的搅拌力道还是要够
如果你水量小但是搅拌力道没有的话
它还是没有办法把它的甜跟厚实度充分的萃取出来
所以当你在缩小你的出水量
降低你出水量的时候还是要记得你的搅拌力道还是要充分
那当你在加大出水量的时候也是要注意到
所有的咖啡粉都有均匀搅拌到
因为我们出水量很大的时候
其实在这一段充足的时间
注水的时间会很短
那注水时间短的时候
如果你没有平均的去绕圈萃取的话
有可能就会造成某一部分的咖啡粉
油被搅拌到
那另外一部分的咖啡粉它没有被搅拌到
它会造成萃取不均的状况
所以当你在做这样子手法调整
不管是缩小水量或是加大水量的时候都要去注意到它搅拌的力道以及充分的均勻的攪拌這樣才能夠讓咖啡的風味
很好的呈現出來
也達到你想要調整的
讓咖啡的風味
變得比較甜厚實
或是比較清爽
突顯它的酸
這是我們在沖煮咖啡的過程當中
用手法就可以來改變
一支咖啡的風味
因為每一支咖啡的調性不同
所以當你用相同的萃取方式的時候
可能會覺得這支咖啡的味道沒有被完全的萃取出來
這個時候你就可以利用手法上來做一些微調
就可以去把咖啡的風味很好的沖煮出來
我們今天用的是分段注水的沖法
把前段萃取酸甜風味跟後段調整濃度的水量分開來
所以我們可以很明顯的看到前段的出水量的差異
那如果用的是一次注水的方式
其實也可以相同套用這個觀念
只是我們在前段注水的水量的部分
我們在出水量可以去加大
那達到我們要的萃取的水量之後
我們接著後段的萃取
但是水量可以縮小
所以有時候我們看咖啡師在沖煮咖啡
看起來好像兩壺的沖把
沒有很大的差異
但是出來的風味卻有不同
有的时候细节就是藏在
这个出水量
它能够影响到咖啡酸甜的风味
那这是今天我们跟大家分享
手冲咖啡慢慢来
如何来调整
咖啡酸甜的风味
请大家订阅我们的频道
我们下次见
拜拜